Uh, a little casual this morning. I, uh, I like wise. Likewise.
How you been?
Friday to you. How about you? How's everything going?
Yeah. Yeah. Happy Friday. Uh, it's been, it's been exciting. It's been, uh, a lot of,
it's been very different from my working life up until this point. Yeah, for sure, for sure.
In what way, uh, just stressful, more hectic, less hectic,
it's, it's, uh, it's a, it's a different kind of stressful, but like one that I'm like welcoming,
very happily. Um, and I just, I'm motivated to work and find myself doing it a lot more than I
did before, but I like, I'm happy to do so. Right, right. Um, yeah. So it's, so it's been exciting
to, to, you know, figure out how to, to make all this happen. Yeah. That's awesome. That's awesome.
Any luck so far or, or still, you know, still looking for, uh, a couple of willing
participants? Uh, still looking for the willing participants, but I am hoping to partner with a veteran
proposal consultant in the industry to kind of bring my technology to his, uh, his network. And so,
yeah, that will hopefully be able to produce something for us. That's pretty cool. That's awesome.
I'm excited to hear it. Yeah. So, yeah, so sorry for the delay. I got your messages. I know you
said you wanted to talk, um, finance wise and everything. And so we're basically from what I recall,
when I saw, I clicked the link, I went through everything and I'm all stuffed up and I got a cold,
so sorry. It looked like it was something like around 6,000 bucks a month is what I saw initially.
Was it right? Was that about correct? Yeah, so that would be if I moved into a retainer, uh,
with you guys, but yeah, that, that was, that is what I had said initially, but the upfront, um,
cost wouldn't, it wouldn't necessitate a $6,000 a month retainer necessarily, like it's flexible.
Okay. Is that linked still live or do you have that? I mean, if you want to pull it up, I'd be
have to look through it. Yeah, I think the link, um, and I'm excited to follow up a PDF as well.
I think really more to the point that I think more to the point is just looking at like what is it that does make sense
for estimates aside? Yeah, rather than let me do that instead. Let me pull
just a second sales budget. I'll share my screen. I just got to find out. This was just where I
lots left off in like August, maybe January. I don't know. So consultants, we can look at tools,
so this has been updated because we also just bought co-star and a couple of new things.
Edition summary. Okay. So over here, we had a guy that we, he wasn't actually a consultant. I
found he was actually a W2, um, kind of a secret side deal situation. Um, so this was projected for
26. This isn't budgeted necessarily. And I'd have to pull final, uh, so this was as of seven
in divided by 712. I would have, it looks like she invoiced 13 grand through July give or take. So I
took that and just worked it out through the rest of the year, uh, divided by 0.6, or wait, 13,000
0.62 divided by 712s. Okay. So basically, it was her 13 grand divided by 712s is what I projected
that to be. I'd have to go back and pull finals. And this was for, uh, that was for basically our
proposals. Jack, this guy was a cold collar and we dicks that. And then there's another guy that we have
now, uh, I can't remember his name, web stuff. I'm just going to put that in. And he is like, uh,
equals, yeah, yeah, yeah. So best synopsis is like 35. Right. Is basically that would be
everything that we had last year. You know, that was just like big total spend was that this,
this Casey is completely piecemeal and just one off. Jack, this guy we got rid of, he was also a special
side deal under the table, but he was, uh, he was like a cold collar and he happened to be one of
our operations guys like brother law or something. Uh, and then this other guy used to work for us and
we basically just have him hold the keys to our website for 600 bucks a month. So he is like,
you know, if it was an hour or two a week, I would be shocked legitimately. Um, so with five or six
hours a month or something like that. So, so that's that piece, uh, tools. I was going to show you
something else too. Oh, yeah. So I just did this yesterday, but I'm going to find it. I guess I
get a lot of stuff that I did yesterday. Um, it's going to be, so as far as stuff that we're trying,
I shared a few things with you. I might have even emailed it. Um, okay. Here's, I'm going to see where
these all come. These two are big and there was some other stuff that I had on here that I thought was,
that was, let me just highlight these for a second that I thought was, uh, pretty applicable to our
conversations. This everything in here is pretty mostly somewhat. And then this is all, like a lot of
this is HubSpot stuff. So I don't know that this necessarily overlaps, but this is just like sort of my
roadmap for what we're going to build out, uh, commission approvals on working activity overview,
sales process, business plan check-ins. Yeah. This is just more like actions that I get to do. Uh,
yeah. So these would probably be the most like PowerPoint redevelopment content strategy,
a total proposal rewrite, better formalizing all of our print material and the ordering process,
like as an example, like if we, I think as we talked about this on the card that one day,
when I was on the way to the airport and feed it, so like, you know, have the standard stuff and then
have a spot for like a name block or the local office and then have all of it on file with a printer
that the local place could just go to that printer and say I want 50 of these and they'll just produce them.
But the RFP agent is the big one. So we've had a couple, uh,
a couple, uh, projects recently and I told you I did get an advanced version of co-pilot,
so we wanted to, that was a big goal was to basically build an agent that whether it was an email
or an inbox, but you basically would have the salesperson send the stuff. It would then digest it,
it would then extract it, it would compare. Okay, here's the output. I need to answer these questions.
Let me go to the document and find those answers. Let me do a DLSS, you know,
and not real similar to what we did at SBM. So yeah, so that's, that's a couple of the things. So
all in all that I, I don't know outside of doing proposals and having that agent set up,
how that real lines back was kind of the list of strategic initiatives. So I was somewhat neglectful
and be a thorough on rereading what you would send and I can pull that back up, but that was, uh,
that's kind of just where my head's at right now is, those are the initiatives and I know that we
spent about 35 grand was consultants last year and whether it's piecemeal or whether it's a little
bit at a time or whether it's project base that, that to start, it would be easier if it was project
base or if it was piecemeal, but, but long term, if we did this RFP agent or something to that extent,
like we talked about, that would be an easier starting point to say, hey, Tim, he's going to build this
thing out. We're going to run this through. We're going to demo it or not demo it. We're going to,
this is, we're going to incorporate this into our process and then there's a, like a maintenance fee
to just keep that agent alive, you know, uh, go ahead.
So I think that RFP, so which of them is most aligned to what you, because you sort of had like
an allocate menu or you had some stuff that you were all working on and building, is there, let's,
let's flip it in reverse. Do you have a list or, you know, kind of that allocate menu that you
could share to say, these are all of the things that are sort of ready to go and then I could just say,
oh, I want that one, I want that. Because my thought is if we take these RFPs and we have a process
and even right now, like, you know, whether it's triggered through a workflow every time to
deal, to drug into proposal and preparation or however we trigger it, we upload all of the information
and then we have a standard output where we have the, you know, the salesperson or the agent is
responsible to format our assessment of the opportunity based on what we want to see and what's in
there that that person then can review at it and revise and then present it out to the team.
And then ideally set up a reverse timeline against when all of our key deliverables will be due
if applicable with a t minus countdown clock against like, okay, if the proposals do on the 19th,
we need finals by the 17th and if the 17th is a Saturday, then it's going to be the 16th and it works
backwards and then, I mean, even if we went beyond, from there, I'm okay just having the person
literally set the email like the meetings themselves, you know, and then the output would be what other
proposal support would come in. The agent, the, the main plan is just to organize the process.
There's an actual deliverable like a proposal or a template or or key documentation or something
like that, that's a piece of it. I'd say that's almost 2.0. But, but if that can be all looped into one,
now all of a sudden, we're not spending, you know, 500 bucks per proposal with Casey
and it's just part of this. So let me pull that for a second. Go ahead.
Okay, so on that concept then, I almost would split this. Let's just assume that's a piece of it
or maybe just a second tier for like a higher level thing. Here to go that route, then we could pick a
project team and say, okay, Joe Murphy, our COO, Matthew Schwartz, our CEO, Eric, uh,
whomever, Doug, our local operator, you're each required to join in on this like I'm
going to set up a one-on-one meeting and I'm going to book a new calendar with the agent. The agent
is going to prompt you as an interview and you're going to have to respond from your capacity,
with your strategy. And then it could basically, it could bring up you right, which we know we can
bring all together to get back to the salesperson to say, okay, based on your key stakeholders
interviews for this project, this is the synthesized strategy. What refinements do you want to make?
Great. Now we'll go put the content together. That's basically right. I mean, that would be,
so would that be the first, or not the first, would that be,
do you envision that as a piece of this?
Yeah. Okay, so what is that? So let's just pursue that route for now.
As comprehensive as this agent project would be, what would that look like for you, for us? I mean,
is it trial? Is it demo? Is it done and ready? Is it something that like we would test it,
proof of concept? And then you would say, this is what it caught. How would you envision that piece
going? Now, do you envision this agent to be this this project? Like we own it or lease it? Like,
is it, hey, it's a one time project, it's $X,000, one time, the whole infrastructure is built on
your server. And then you just bring it into me for oil changes every quarter, or is it the flip
where this is my proprietary IP? This is my tech. You pay me a subscription to use this as long as you
want to. Okay. And what would that, what would that look like cost wise from your perspective to
go that route? The monthly ongoing is you have to maintain certain levels of subscription. I would
figure that we should have at least a quarterly check-in where we're doing that, that quote, unquote,
oil change, that shouldn't be crazy. And then there would be a, I'm sure some sort of project base
or, hey, we need this, it's outside of the scope. What would it cost to do this? But what would that
initial implementation phase look like in your mind? Well, it's already done. It's just what do you
want to pay for? Well, what do you say 50? I thought that was the $5,500 was, I thought that was
like per month, like ongoing, or was that one time that I misread it? Here, I think I have here,
because that's what I just looked at. Let me just put on my other screen so I can see if I can
do what? Well, perhaps $6,000 was like, that's 72 grade of a year. And that's literally
borderline higher someone for that, you know what I mean? Not to do this, not with that skill,
but with a person to do a thing in root of entry ways. Yeah, so the other, did I tell you about
trampoline ag.ai? Okay, that's something that I think is a friend of a friend of somebody,
and that was way expensive. I have to go back and see what that looked like, but that was one of
these ongoing, like a subscription-based thing or purpose-based thing, and that was something where
it sucked, and it was, you know, expensive. If you don't, if you don't, if you don't,
if you want to reason that or static or a new link, I'll re-look at it through this lens,
see if it looks like I'll get the other thing that I would want to know is kind of like what system
configuration, what's the minimum specs that we have to have for this to work? What subscriptions,
what licenses can you use about advanced copilot? What would we need as the base for you to be able to work
with for this to work with? Why would you vote for those? I would just need to know what we would
need from a licensing perspective. I could get with RIT guy Joe and just say, hey, we would need this
and this. Do you see any issues with that? And if he says no, it's not a problem. And maybe I could
even set up a quick call with you with him. Did you say, hey, here's what I would need. Could you,
is this fine? If he's like, yeah, this would not be a problem to be able to implement this,
then there's no firewall issues, there's no anything else. Then he would just have to set up that
change whether that point is $6,000 or whatever it is. Here's another word of this. And then as we can see,
the proof is gone or run hypothetical sprue on your system, but then I think he would say like, yeah,
we should absolutely do this because we'll cut our spend significantly and we'll be able to
improve the quality of every proposal, not just the highest, highest caliber ones.
Right, gotcha. And I think there would, and I don't get around, I would also need a good list
of where all of the spots of customization so that I can enhance and bolster our content library
with the right naming conventions for this is our Atlanta map, this is our whatever, or like,
at what point does the user have to get involved and actually pull the right images or documents or things?
Yeah, so if you want to, I want to make sure you have time to get on your thing. Go ahead and
reset me that thing and then let's set up a call for whenever to do that like like a demo or
a pilot, like here's some stuff on your side. Let's see what comes out because if there's a proof
and concept that you say, I said this, this is what came back, I literally watched it happen.
Sounds awesome. Look forward to it. Catch up soon. See you.